[Applause]
this boeing
747-300 did belong to the iranian cargo
company mahan air
last year they sold it to the venezuelan
firm empress or cargo
the us says it did not authorize that
transaction which broke its export
control laws they want the plane
confiscated
iran denies the accusations while
venezuela wants the aircraft back
the plane that was carrying out a
fundamental humanitarian mission for
venezuela has been kidnapped by
argentina they've robbed us on the
orders of an imperialist court in the
united states
venezuela raises its voice in protest
and calls for unity with the honest
people of argentina
an argentine judge released 12 of the 19
crew members seven remain three
venezuelans and four iranians among them
the pilot colombrissa gassemi
the us believes he belongs to the cudd's
force of iran's revolutionary guard
sanctioned by the us but not argentina
as a terror organization
it's a case shrouded in confusion and
counter claims
what we do know for now is that the
boeing 747 belonging to the venezuelan
cargo company empressor has been
impounded here at buenos aires's assaisa
airport for two months
israel has praised the argentine
authorities for its action suggesting at
least some of the crew might be involved
in smuggling weapons
argentina was in the 1990s the victim of
two attacks it said iran was involved in
one on the israeli embassy and one on a
jewish cultural center
no one's been brought to justice for
either bombing and jewish organizations
in argentina one of possible future
attacks
they want the plane and its crew
investigated
if we see a link i don't know if there's
a link with the attacks in 1992 and 1994
but it could be a preparatory mission
for an attack in argentina for somewhere
else in latin america
the lawyer acting for the detained pilot
told al jazeera the case was political
as well as legal involved a lot of
paperwork and is unlikely to be resolved
anytime soon
meanwhile the plane remains firmly on
the ground
daniel schweiner al-jazeera buenos aires